[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend an
diesem stürmischen Freitag wieder zieht
ein Orkantief über Deutschland im Norden
Deutschlands und Teilen von
Nordrhein-Westfalen wurde vorsorglich
der Bahnverkehr eingestellt in anderen
europäischen Ländern haben die Stürme
heute schon schwere Schäden angerichtet
in Irland England Belgien und den
Niederlanden kamen mindestens acht
Menschen ums Leben in London wurde sogar
erstmals die Warnstufe rot ausgerufen an
seinem Stern
die erste sturmwelle trifft heute
Großbritannien Spitzen
Windgeschwindigkeit
196 km pro Stunde Rekord auf der Insel
Bäume und auch das Dach des Millennium
Domes in London machtlos gegen den Wind
der auch so manchem Piloten alles
abverlangt wenig später ist der Sturm in
den Niederlanden Amsterdam beklagt
Todesopfer Bäume krachen nieder
erschlagen Fußgänger Rad und auch
Autofahrer
Zayn App ist da bedeutet bei uns in
Deutschland seit dem Nachmittag leere
Gleise und volle Bahnhöfe es fährt
nichts mehr der regional- und
Fernverkehr im gesamten Norden
Deutschlands eingestellt
für Samstag und dafür Sonntag gedacht
waren können auch noch flexibel bis
Sonntag nächster Woche genutzt werden
und doch ist es der nächste Sturm Stress
für alle die die im Norden unterwegs
sind relativ
unangenehm diese Situation weil wir vor
allen Dingen nicht in der Bahn nicht
informiert worden dass ab 15 Uhr hier
einfach keinen Weiterkommen mehr ist wir
wollen eigentlich morgen weiter nach
London von Köln und da können wir
wahrscheinlich auch nicht hin
das heißt ich muss Termine absagen
Natur aus Natur da kann man nichts
machen
viel machen müssen die Einsatzkräfte es
werden wohl anstrengende Tage mal wieder
schon die ersten sturmausläufe am frühen
Abend wen Lkw in Gräben und Ringen auch
sehr große Bäume nieder
an der Küste wie hier in Cuxhaven sind
Sie gerüstet und vorsichtig beim letzten
Spaziergang vor der Sturmnacht
wieder Sturm Alarm in Deutschland viel
Wind und höchstwahrscheinlich auch viel
Wasser Sturmfluten drohen in den
kommenden Stunden an der Küste der
Nordsee
geschickt Fabian Köhler ist für uns ganz
hoch oben an der Nordseeküste von
Ostfriesland in Norddeich und Fabian man
sieht da bläst es schon heftig
ja man muss wirklich sagen dass sie in
den letzten ein zwei Stunden der Sturm
noch mal dermaßen zugelegt hat das ist
wirklich schwierig ist sich auf den
Beinen zu halten wir stehen ja
eigentlich im Windschatten unseres
Hotels auf der Terrasse hier hinter uns
ist die Hafenanlage von Norddeich dort
waren wir vorhin selber noch um ein paar
Bilder zu drehen mittlerweile hat die
Polizei das Gelände abgesperrt man
rechnet dort sicherlich auch mit
Überflutung und es ist wirklich
lebensgefährlich sich weiter draußen
aufzuhalten ich hatte vor einer guten
Stunde die Möglichkeit mit der Feuerwehr
hier aus dem Landkreis zu sprechen und
der Kollege dort sagte dass ich schon zu
150 Einsätzen ausrücken müssten das ist
wirklich deutlich mehr als sie erwartet
hatten und das schlimmste mag ja
womöglich noch kommen für die Nacht es
sind bisher vor allen Dingen Bäume
umgekippt auch einen Bericht von einem
Baum der in ein Haus gefallen soll sagte
die Feuerwehr das wäre jetzt unbewohnbar
also die ersten Schäden gibt es
mittlerweile die gute Nachricht ist die
Leute haben sich eigentlich an die
Warnmeldung gehalten die meisten Leute
sind wirklich zu Hause geblieben und es
gibt bisher auch noch keine Bildung von
verletzten Personen hier oben an der
Küste
auch besser mal in Sicherheit wir
schauen noch mal weiter hoch in den
Norden nämlich nach List auf Sylt das
ist ja der nördlichste Ort Deutschlands
da steht Claas Thomsen Klaas wie hat
sich denn die Insel auf den Sturm und
mögliche Fluten vorbereitet
ja ich stehe am Hafen von List
eigentlich total geschützt am Strand wo
der Sturm mit voller Wucht aufs Land
trifft da können wir uns jetzt nicht
unterhalten aber trotzdem wird es ja
auch hier ordentlich sehr kräftig gerade
es war ein bisschen unheimlich vor zwei
Stunden hörte der Sturm kurzzeitig mal
richtig auf aber dann hol dir einfach
nur Luft das war diese berühmte Ruhe vor
dem Sturm und jetzt wird es mir niedlich
wieder mehr man muss allerdings sagen
die Insulaner sind natürlich sehr
vertraut mit solchen sturmlagen der
Bahnverkehr wurde ja heute Nachmittag
schon eingestellt
strandtreppen wurden abmontiert und
gesichert damit der sie nicht ins Meer
gerissen werden was in den letzten
Jahren öfter mal passiert ist auch hier
in List was hat dich sehr teuer ist dann
und man muss aber auch sagen diese
Sicherungsmaßnahmen die gerade auch
schon sehr viel früher im Sommer wird ja
sehr viel Sand hier an den Weststrand
gespült damit der blanke Hans wieder
stürmische die stürmische Nordsee hier
heißt sich das im Winter holen kann und
erst wenn dieser ganze Sand weggerissen
ist dann wird es manchmal für Sylt etwas
kritisch wenn das dann geht aber dieser
Sturm hier ist ja vor allem ich war da
in den Spitzen so aggressiv ist er hat
130 bis 160 Stundenkilometer aber
zwischendrin wird es auch mal wieder ein
bisschen ruhiger deswegen hoffen die
Insulaner dass sie morgen aufwachen und
sind mit einem blauen Auge davon
gekommen und können sich dann vielleicht
langsam mal ein bisschen auf den
Frühling freuen das hoffen wir dann auch
für die Sylter aber auch für die anderen
Nordseeinseln danke schön soweit nach
List auf Sylt
wie sich das in den nächsten Stunden
weiterentwickeln wird das berichten die
Kollegen im heute schon mal Update
deswegen der brenzligen Wetterlage auch
früher auf Sendung geht als vorgesehen
nämlich heute bereits um
23:50 Uhr
kommen wir zur ja ebenfalls turbulenten
Großwetterlage der Weltpolitik die
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz hat
begonnen das stell Dich ein der
Weltpolitik das immer auch ein Ort war
um Diplomatie zu betreiben Konflikte zu
entschärfen oder im Gegenteil auf
offener Bühne hart auszutragen es hat
dort schon manch legendäre Auftritte
gegeben an einen erinnert man sich in
diesen Tagen aber besonders an die
Brandrede des Vladimir Putin im Jahre
2007 er überraschte damals mit seinem
Furor gegen amerikanische Übermacht und
nato-ost Erweiterung und manchen
schwarmte damals erstmals dass ich da
eine neue Ost-West Konfrontation
entwickelt diesmal ist in München nicht
mal mehr eine Vertreter der russischen
Regierung anwesend Matthes
feldhoff-bericht
es ist wahrscheinlich die größte
Schwäche dieser Konferenz der Westen
redet mit sich selbst beim Auftakt
sprechen die deutsche Außenministerin
und die amerikanischer Kollege vor allem
über Russland mit Russland können sie
nicht reden die russische Regierung
verweigert den Dialog offenbar hat man
in Moskau keine Lust auf die Vorwürfe
des Westens Russland spricht mit seinem
Truppenaufmarsch eine
inakzeptare Drohung aus gegenüber der
Ukraine aber auch gegenüber uns allen
und unser
friedensarchitektur in Europa diese
Krise ist keine Ukraine Krise sie ist
eine Russlandkrise auch den
rückzugsmeldungen die Russland in den
letzten Tagen verbreitete schenkt der
Westen kaum glauben dafür gäbe es keine
Belege das bei Überraschung trotz der
Behauptung Russlands ist hier gerade
Kräfte von der Grenze ab das ist nicht
passiert im Gegenteil wir beobachten
zusätzliche Kräfte die in Richtung
Grenze gebracht werden darunter Truppen
die Teil eines Angriffs wären
seit Wochen geben sich die
Regierungschefs bei Putin die Klinke in
die Hand Frankreichs Präsident macron
der türkische Präsident Erdogan zuletzt
der deutsche Kanzler Olaf Scholz mein
näher mal weiter weg vom russischen
Präsidenten platziert bekommen sie
allerdings nur wolkige versprechen
serviert
jetzt haben die Amerikaner einen Brief
von Maximalforderung bekommen
und Osteuropa das ist einfach nicht
miteinander vereinbar und ich glaube man
muss da schlicht sagen wenn die Russen
nicht wollen wollen sie nicht
bewegend der Auftritt des ehemaligen
boxweltmeisters und Kiefer
Bürgermeisters Vitali Klitschko er dankt
der deutschen Regierung für die
finanzielle Unterstützung bittet aber
auch mit Waffenlieferung zu helfen im
ZDF Interview zeigt er seine
Unzufriedenheit mit Berlin wir brauchen
eine ich möchte betonen
verteidigungsverteidigungswaffen weil
mit Kopfkissen können wir nicht unsere
landwirtage gegen eine demekteste arme
in der Welt während der Amerikaner
weitere Militärhilfen verspricht und wie
zufällig die 650 Millionen Dollar
militärunterstützung erwähnt muss Bär
Bock einräumen dass die 5000
soldatenhelme nicht zufriedenstellen
können aber Waffenlieferung Kämpfe
Deutschland nicht in Frage
es tut mir leid dass es nur 5000 waren
aber es gibt ja eine neue Liste wo wir
noch mal schauen was wir tun können aber
wegen unserer Geschichte haben wir eine
andere Verantwortung für die Erhaltung
des Friedens als andere
München ist wieder mal der Brennpunkt
der internationalen Krisen Diplomatie
allerdings ist nur die entschlossene
Stimme des Westens zu hören durch das
Fernbleiben ist die Stimme Russlands
zumindest in München verstummt
und von der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz zugeschaltet ist
uns der Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
Stoltenberg the evening ist das
dorttenberg
selbst boykottiert diese Veranstaltung
erstmals seit Jahrzehnten gleichzeitig
hat Putin ein großes Manöver mit
ballistischen Raketen da geht's um
Nuklearwaffen auch angekündigt für
morgen empfinden sie das als eine
weitere Provokation
oh befestival Situation
ist sehr sehr schwierig herausfordernd
für der europäische Sicherheit und das
liegt an diesem Aufmarsch truppenaufbau
an der Grenze zur Ukraine aber dann eben
auch mit dieser aggressive Rhetorik die
eben Grundprinzip in der europäischen
Sicherheit verletzt z.B das
Selbstbestimmungsrecht für jedes Land
über seinen eigenen Weg und wenn diese
Forderungen nicht erfüllt werden sagen
Sie es gibt ernsthafte
militärisch-technische Konsequenzen und
das ist ziemlich schwerwiegend deswegen
appellieren wir zu deeskalieren sich mit
der Nattern einen Tisch zu setzen und
Bemühungen zu unternehmen eine
diplomatische Lösung zu finden
wir sprechen von Eskalation ist ganz
interessant der russische Außenminister
lavrov sagte gestern diese ganze
Eskalation die fände eigentlich nur in
den Köpfen des Westens statt bzw in den
Gehirnen des Westen zu wörtlich oder
nannte explizit auch ihr Gehirn Herr
Stoltenberg und sagte alle Fragen dazu
was ist damit auf sich haben solle
müsste man eigentlich ihnen stellen wenn
dieses Quote kennen dieses Zitat möchten
sie darauf reagieren
es kann doch keine Zweifel geben das ist
ganz erhebt ein ganz erhebliche
Konzentration eine Massierung russischer
Streitkräfte in der freien und an ihren
Grenzen gegeben hat und wir haben
keinerlei Zeichen einer Deeskalation
gesehen im Gegenteil
wir sehen dass dieser truppenaufbau
weitergeht und das sind Informationen
die alle Natur Verbündeten und ihre
Geheimdienste haben aber das kommt auch
aufs offenen Quellen sozialen Medien und
so weiter wird das bestätigt und gilt
dann zu kommerziellen Satelliten also es
kann keinen Zweifel geben dass wir nun
die größte Konzentration militärischer
Streitkräfte in Europa seit dem Ende des
Zweiten Kalten Krieges erleben viel mehr
als ein Manöver und nur russland hat
auch die Kapazität und die hat es ganz
sicher
einzunaschieren ohne Vorwarnzeit aber zu
spät
und sich dann auf den Weg zu begeben zu
einer politischen Lösung und genau das
darüber appellieren werden Russland
und nicht gehört zu werden und der
amerikanische Präsident beiden sagt er
rechne sogar mit einem Einmarsch einer
Invasion in den nächsten Tagen eine so
konkrete Ankündigung gab es von
amerikanischer Seite schon mal und dann
passierte sozusagen erstmal nicht viel
welche Strategie steckt dahinter immer
wieder zu sagen also die Russen greifen
bald an und dann lassen die das aber
trotzdem
the Whiskey song the capital bra die
Kapazitäten sind da die Fähigkeiten
russland hat Streitkräfte vor Ort und
auch die Unterstützung logistiktransport
Munition und so weiter sie können einen
Angriff jederzeit ohne Vorwarnung vom
Zaun brechen das ist gewiss dass ich
wissen werde aber wir wissen nicht
welche Intentionen hinter Russlands
Plänen stehen mit so massive aufgebauten
Streitkräften und allem was wir aus der
Vergangenheit Wissen von Russland den
Einsatz von Gewalt gegen die Ukraine und
dann diese aggressive Rhetorik und genau
deswegen
gehen wir so klare Botschaften in
Richtung nach Russland ist fährt sehr
teuer für euch wenn ihr einmarschiert in
der Ukraine
wir haben natürlich unsere Kräfte
westlich der Grenze ein wenig aufgehört
aufgebaut
wo bin ich auch noch zu schützen aber
weiterhin appellieren wir haben Russland
nicht rein zu marschieren sondern nach
hinten zu marschieren und sich um eine
friedliche Lösung zu bemühen
also Truppen werden bewegt malvor mal
zurück es gibt immer wieder Gefechte in
der Ostukraine es gibt mehrere oder
weniger größere Zusammenstöße mit NATO
kampfliegern über Mittelmeer die NATO
bleibt schön an der Ostflanke verstärkt
immer weiter das alles wird die Ukraine
Schwächen auffüllen und die NATO
vielleicht auch zermürben da sagen
manche in Deutschland wäre es nicht
einfacher wenn die Ukraine dieses diese
NATO Mitgliedschaft jetzt einfach
aufgibt sagt okay wir bleiben ein
neutraler Start und dann gibt Putin Ruhe
the princible der Grundsatz ist das
eigentlich Wichtige besagt dass die
Ukraine entscheiden muss ob sie in die
NATO möchte oder nicht und dann liegt es
an den 30 Bündnispartnern zu entscheiden
ob die Ukraine die Normen erfüllt damit
sie beitreten kann wir wollen nicht
wieder niemals wieder eine Weltordnung
mit Einfluss wären und die Großmächte
entscheiden was die Nachbarn dürfen und
was sie nicht dürfen und das geht weit
hinaus über die Ukraine denn was
russland fordert ist ja dass wir jedes
neue Mitglied abweisen sollen wir werden
genau
die haben sich nicht beworben und meine
Mitgliedschaft aber sie wollen nicht
dass die NATO in die Türken verstehst
irgendwann einmal
Russland den sie für eine
sicherheitsvereinbarung vorlegen und
dann noch etwas sie wollen wir alle
Streitkräfte die ganze NATO
Infrastruktur Abziehen von den
Bündnispartnern dieser seit 1997
beigetreten sind und dann hätten wir
irgendwann Bündnispartner erster und
zweiter Klasse und das werden wir nie
akzeptieren 1 Klasse im Westen zweiter
Klasse im Osten das geht nicht
Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg ich
danke für das Gespräch
das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am späten Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet jetzt am Abend kam die
Meldung dass die NATO die
Einsatzbereitschaft ihrer schnellen
Eingreiftruppe erhöht das betrifft
mehrere tausend Soldaten auch deutsche
was bei der NATO befürchtet wird ist
eine sogenannte falls Flag eine
Operation unter falscher Flagge mit der
Russland einen Vorfall inszeniert als
Vorwand für einen Einmarsch die
US-Regierung leuchtet dafür ja schon
seit Tagen mögliche Szenarien aus um die
Welt Öffentlichkeit sozusagen
vorzuwarnen auch das seine Form von
Kriegsstrategie zu versuchen dem
Gegenüber das Überraschungsmoment zu
nehmen als mögliche Variante wird ein
fingierter Angriff auf russische
Staatsbürger im Donbass gehandelt dazu
würde jedenfalls passen dass die Pro
russischen Separatisten die dortige
Bevölkerung jetzt dazu aufrufen sich
über die Grenze nach Russland in
Sicherheit zu bringen
Trümmerteile auf der Straße sie stammen
von einem explodierten Auto geparkt war
das Fahrzeug das dem Chef der Volksmiliz
gehören soll neben dem Regierungsgebäude
in Donezk verletzt wurde niemand schon
am Nachmittag
Fliegeralarm im Separatisten Gebiet die
Anführer der selbst ernannten
Volksrepubliken Donez und luhansk warnen
vor einem Angriff des ukrainischen
Militärs
der Präsident der Ukraine selensky wird
in der nächsten Zeit an die Militärs den
Befehl erteilen den Plan für den
Einmarsch auf das Territorium der
Volksrepubliken Don jetzt und luhansk zu
realisieren
Beweise legt puschillin dafür nicht vor
und genau vor diesem Szenario war immer
wieder gewarnt worden dass der Krieg in
der Ostukraine neu entfesselt wird durch
einen angeblichen ukrainischen Angriff
oder Anschlag die ukrainische Regierung
in Kiew weist die Vorwürfe einmal mehr
entschieden zurück währenddessen kommt
auch aus Moskau eine alte Forderung
Wladimir Putin fordert bei einem Treffen
mit dem belarussischen Diktator
Geschenke die Ukraine auf direkt mit den
Separatisten im Donbass zu verhandeln
was Kiew entschieden ablehnt
muss ich mit Vertretern des don-bass an
den Verhandlungstisch setzen und sich
auf politische militärische
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre Maßnahmen
zur Beendigung des Konflikts einigen je
früher das geschieht desto besser leider
sehen wir im Moment das Gegenteil einer
Verschärfung der Situation im Donbass
und in Moskau tut man so als haben man
damit nichts zu tun am Abend wurden die
ersten Kinder weggebracht aus Donezk
nach Roßdorf am Don in Süd Russland
und jetzt macht Hans mit den Nachrichten
weiter da geht's aber auch erst noch mal
um dieses Thema der Russland
ukraine-konflikt ist noch Einschätzung
von Finanzminister Lindner eines der
Risiken für den Aufschwung der
Weltwirtschaft Lindner äußerte sich nach
den Beratungen der Finanzminister und
Notenbankchefs der 20 führenden
Industrie und Schwellenländer als
weitere Risiken für die Weltwirtschaft
nannte er die anhaltend hohe Inflation
Unterbrechungen bei Lieferketten sowie
Materialengpässe infolge der
corona-pandemie
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann hat
anlässlich des zweiten jahrestages des
rassistischen Anschlags in Hanau von
einem Versagen des Staates gesprochen
und habe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
vor mörderischem Hass und Wahn nicht
schützen können staatliche Stellen
hätten sich später gegenüber Betroffenen
unangemessen verhalten vor zwei Jahren
hatte ein 43-jähriger Deutscher in Hanau
aus rassistischen Motiven neun Menschen
erschossen das Bundesinnenministerium
plant bis Ostern ein Gesetzespaket zur
Bekämpfung von Rechtsextremismus
zur Börse für den deutschen Leitindex
Dax ging es heute insgesamt ins Minus
und wir schauen bei den Einzelwerten
genauer auf die Allianz mit Jahreszahlen
weil er gerade wie sie in die Zahlen aus
ja die Allianz hat im vergangenen Jahr
richtig gut verdient einen Rekordgewinn
eingefahren aber die Zahlen werden
überschattet von Rechtsstreitigkeiten in
den USA die den Versicherer Milliarden
kosten eine juristische Hängepartie die
sich nun schon seit anderthalb Jahren
hinzieht Stürme Fluten Niedrigzinsen
konnten dem Geschäft nichts anhaben das
größte Risiko liegt für die Allianz
aktuell bei der US-Justiz amerikanische
Investoren haben den Versicherer
verklagt weil sie von einer Allianz von
Tochter angeblich krisensichere Papiere
gekauft und damit Milliarden verloren
hatten teures Debakel 3,7 Milliarden
Euro hat der DAX-Konzern dafür
zurückgelegt die Summe könnte noch höher
ausfallen denn noch verhandelt die
Allianz weil aber das Liebe Geschäft
besser läuft als gedacht kann der
Versicherer die milliardenzahlung
verkraften gut fürs Image sind solche
Rechtsstreitigkeiten aber natürlich nie
die milliardenschweren Rückstellungen
belasten auch die Papiere der Allianz
nach einem bisher guten Lauf heute dick
im Minus unter Druck auf der DAX der nur
knapp über 15.000 Punkten schließt
bestimmendes Thema nach wie vor der
Russland Ukraine Konflikt der
Aktienmarkt ist zurzeit einfach nichts
für schwache Nerven
und noch mal zum stürmischen Wetter und
den Gefahren der Deutsche Wetterdienst
hat amtliche Unwetterwarnungen
herausgegeben vor orkanartigen Böen bis
hin zu extremen Orkanböen vor allem in
der nördlichen Hälfte Deutschlands aber
auch für Teile von Bayern für die
Nordseeküste gibt es eine Warnung vor
einer schweren Sturmflut mehr dazu
gleich in unserem ausführlichen
Wetterbericht nach der
olympiabberichterstattung
nördlich der griechischen Insel Korfu
ist am Morgen eine Autofähre aus noch
bislang umgekehrter Ursache in Brand
geraten sie war auf dem Weg von
Griechenland nach Süditalien der
Großteil der rund 300 Passagiere und die
Besatzung konnten gerettet werden
mindestens 11 Menschen gelten als
vermisst und klar ist ob es auf dem
Schiff auch blinde Passagiere gab die
Route wird seit Jahren auch von
Migranten genutzt
zur corona-lage in Deutschland
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
sieht den Höhepunkt der omegonwelle
überschritten aber man sei noch nicht
wirklich in sicheren Gewässern sagte er
in Berlin Lauterbach appellierte an alle
Ministerpräsidenten dem beschlossenen
Stufenplan für Lockerungen einzuhalten
laut Robert-Koch-Institut ist in den
Krankenhäusern der Höhepunkt der
Belastungen noch nicht überschritten
und jetzt die Corona Zahlen des RKI
demnach sinkt die sieben Tage Inzidenz
erneut leicht auf jetzt fast
1372 die Gesundheitsämter meldeten dem
RKI 220.000 48 Neuinfektionen das sind
20.124 weniger als vergangenen Freitag
innerhalb eines Tages kamen 264
Todesfälle hinzu
264 tote gestern waren es 261 allein
diese Zahlen bestätigen viele geimpfte
darin dass es besser ist diesen Virus
mit bestmöglichem Immunschutz zu
begegnen viele ungeimpfte halten dem
entgegen dass sie den neuen Methoden der
mRNA Impfstoffe nicht trauen diesen
Misstrauen können Wissenschaftler mit
noch so vielen Erklärungen begegnen oder
darauf verweisen dass inzwischen
weltweit Milliarden Dosen dieser
Impfstoffe verabreicht wurden damit
dringen sie aber zu vielen Skeptikern
nicht durch deshalb setzten
Gesundheitspolitiker große Hoffnungen
auf die Zulassung von novawachs er ist
sozusagen ein klassischer mit
altbekannter Technik produzierter
Impfstoff wenn dazu von Sven Klaas
noch ist der novawachs Impfstoff nicht
da noch nutzen sie auch in Stuttgart nur
die schon länger zugelassen Corona
Impfstoffe die Nachfrage niedrig wie
überall in Deutschland vor allem kommen
kaum noch Menschen die bislang nicht
geimpft sind
die Hoffnung hier wie anderswo der neue
novawax Impfstoff könnte bisher
ungeimpfte doch noch zum Umdenken
bewegen am 21
Februar das heißt am Montag erwarten wir
1,4 Millionen Dosen des also novawags
Impfstoffes in der Woche darauf noch mal
eine Million dann mit einer gewissen
Verzögerung also
weitere also charchen zunächst einmal
soll der novawachs Impfstoff vorrangig
für bisher ungeimpfte Beschäftigte im
Gesundheitswesen eingesetzt werden
bundesweit gibt es bereits mehrere
10.000 Voranmeldungen für eine novawachs
Impfung Interessenten auch in Stuttgart
800 Menschen
vorregistriert und angemeldet wir hoffen
am Donnerstag nächster Woche starten zu
können das sind teilweise Beschäftigte
aus dem Gesundheitswesen für die die
Impfpflicht gilt aber auch Menschen aus
anderen Branchen der novawachs Impfstoff
unterscheidet sich von den bisher
verwendeten die mRNA Impfstoffe von
biontech und moderner im Körper einen
Bauplan für einen kleinen Teil des
Erregers das sogenannte spike-protein
die Körperzellen bauen dann nach diesem
Plan selbst das ungefährliche Protein
des Coronavirus darauf wiederum reagiert
das Immunsystem
beim proteinbasierten novawachs im Stoff
werden außerhalb des Körpers künstlich
hergestelltes bikeproteine gespritzt auf
die das Immunsystem dann reagiert z.B
Grippeimpfstoffe funktionieren genauso
teilweise wird novawachs auch als
todimpfstoff bezeichnet eine Frage der
Definition
historisch hat man unterschieden
zwischen Lebendimpfstoffen also
Impfstoffe die sich im Körper noch
vermehren können häufig einfach
abgeschwächte Formen des Virus und Tod
im Stoffen alles was ich nicht vermehren
kann da in dieser Definition passt das
rein nach dieser Definition werden aber
auch mRNA im Stoffen tot im Stoffe ganz
streng genommen wird manchmal unter
Totem Stoffen aber auch das verstanden
dass einfach das Virus hergenommen wird
abgetötet wird wenn Sie so wollen oder
inaktiviert wird was bei novawatz nicht
der Fall ist auch deshalb bleiben manche
Skeptiker zurückhaltend auch hier bei
den sogenannten Spaziergängern in
Brackenheim in Baden-Württemberg
aber ich warte da erstmal ab ob es dann
auch ja wie sieht es entwickelt das
heißt novawax spielt dann auch keine
Rolle also für mich nicht ne
also ich vertraue den ganzen
Impfstoffherstellern gar nicht
einige bisher ungeimpfte von einer
Impfung überzeugen die Schutzwirkung
jedenfalls liegt laut Zulassungsstudien
nach zwei Dosen bei rund 90%, die
Wirksamkeit ist somit vergleichbar mit
den mRNA Impfstoffen
später im Programm geht's dann heiterer
weiter mit der heute-show und Jan
Böhmermann und direkt danach gibt's dann
unsere heute schon mal Update mit
Gundula Gause auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
da ist der Orkan herangekommen meine
Damen und Herren erstmal einen schönen
guten Abend zehnerpat erstmal seine
Warmfront über uns geschickt und dann
kam die Kaltfront schon nachmittags ging
das los und jetzt aktuell liegt sie hier
im äußersten Westen und sie sehen wie
sie sich an die Alpen schmiegt und genau
diese Karlsruhe schauen wir uns noch
einmal genauer an das ist dieses blaue
Band sie sehen die kräftigsten
Regenfälle und sie sehen auch sie hat
Deutschland schon fast vollkommen
verlassen es gab da schon enorme
Sturmböen aber wir schauen uns jetzt mal
nur die Orkanböen an also
Windgeschwindigkeiten über 117 km pro
Stunde es gab schon einige Rekorde
Spiekeroog Büsum überall sehr hohe
Windgeschwindigkeiten 143 km pro Stunde
gab es bisher schon und in der Nacht
wird es wahrscheinlich noch mehr werden
wir schauen uns das Orkan Windfeld an
das sind diese lila Pfeile schauen Sie
wie sich dieses organfilmsfeld über
gesamten Norden und Nordosten
Deutschlands wälzt und morgen früh
pfeift es dann noch am längsten über
Rügen und Usedom danach wird der Tag
aber deutlich ruhiger in der Nacht also
gibt es kräftige Schauer hier im Norden
und das droht eine schwere Sturmflut an
der Nordsee und morgen wird es dann für
viele ein ganz freundlicher Tag im
Norden sind noch etliche Schauer
unterwegs und für die neue Woche gilt es
bleibt zwar windig und wechselhaft wird
aber auch etwas kühler guten Abend